so the question for today if you choose
to answer is I have no idea that's
that's a tough question
Wow oh my god oh that is a hard question
[Music]
what's your wildest dream my wildest
dream oh my god
probably have a gunfight while I'm
falling from like you know space just
kind of falling down all over thereit's
and having a gunfight pretty wicked just
becoming a cat we live in an ice palace
on the top of a mountain in Iceland
surrounded by a army of penguins to me
Queen of England
pull off a heist like a casino heist
that'd be that'd be really cool my
wildest dream
why
inside a big lawnmower with wings
to live in a cottage with 15 dogs flying
with the unicorn that poops rainbow
doing so much stuff like going skydiving
going at Disneyland every day and label
me so I went to Kent I was in
Canyonlands in there there are a bunch
of these candy Watchers
and then I and then one of them attacked
me and then I just woke up it was weird
do you kind of wish that would happen
through this why this dream is to commit
his teachers because he thinks were both
crazy
yeah is that right yeah
[Music]
I can say that in camera it's a boring
wildest dream torture museum yeah why I
don't know I just thought it's boring
again oh I just would love to like work
behind the scenes cataloging my wildest
dream is to be on Broadway in New York
and go to college at NYU Tisch and I
star in a Broadway show I've always
wanted to do that it's like my wildest
dream my wildest dream is to adopt like
hundreds of kids from all over the world
especially like developing worlds and
bring them to the US and raise them and
give them everything that they'll ever
need and send them off to college and
then just to become good people who
change the world I think my wildest
dream is to see my kids
because life is so short and there's so
many things that happened in life that
you don't get to live out of everything
but that thing that's one of my wildest
dreams
[Music]
[Music]
just to have a wife and live in a simple
house that's it there's a live a simple
life that's that's it that's my waters
room I guess right now because of the
political climate just for us as a
nation to come together to like make it
impact in my community it sounds kind of
cheesy I know it's always been like I
want to shape the city of Tijuana I
think to do that be to like finish a
doctorate degree or something like that
I think that would be like one of my
wildest dreams to be able to have that
and go back to my community and make a
change to find a 40-foot beaver
motorhome for $100,000 to get rich
without doing anything to get a
girlfriend to get a girlfriend to retire
right now my wildest dream is to pursue
my realistic dreams of opening a
restaurant
probably to own a fashion magazine one
day I gotta say my wildest dream is
performing on that stage right over
there to become a comedian mother yeah
me too we had put the film on you have
been too nervous cozies I don't know
that I can answer that question I think
anything that I dream of I think can be
done so it doesn't seem too wild for me
it's really unrealistic but just sort of
have like no like boundaries and just
sort of be like free to do it I want
like just travel all over the place and
like try new things every day what kind
of boundaries do you think you have
right now that we don't work parents the
loss money you know I don't know I have
to be happy would you say that you're
not happy right now I wouldn't say that
I'm not happy I just think to be happy
all the time
personally I just like to see all my
grandchildren get home from various
trips everybody's safe make something
new like Steve Jobs some new technology
that the world hasn't seen yet my
wildest dream my wildest dream is to be
a millionaire ruler of all of California
California is my home you know I don't
want too big I don't want to roll like
all of America too hard
presidency too much pressure you know I
don't want to be in the spotlight but I
want to all the power I'd make a nice a
nice plot of land for myself my own
little city and then from there I would
rule all the other cities and then this
next part is you're going to say the
phrase how sweet it is and then finish
it however you'd like okay so whenever
you're ready how sweet it is to be happy
how sweet it is to live this life today
how sweet it is to be with family how
sweet it is to be loved by you how sweet
it is to live in San Diego how sweet it
is the cats exist how sweet it is to be
heading off to college how sweet it is
to be with people you love how sweet it
is to be confident how sweet it is to
teach first grade how sweet it is to be
artistic how sweet it is to be happy how
sweet it is to be here with my son and
enjoy
beautiful day
[Music]
how sweet it is sharing fries with my
wife
[Music]
what's up guys my name is Brian and I'm
the owner of this channel I'm also the
person behind the camera and I thought
I'd take a minute to thank all the
subscribers I gained so far and maybe
ask the new year's to hit the subscribe
button if you like this episode or if
you're a fan of my channel in general I
mean a lot thank you